parfait début d'un tronc magnifique
comment allez-vous il ya un an et un
mois je crois précisément j'avais fait
un test d'intelligence sur mon chien
pour vous prouver qui faisait partie de
l'élite de la société qu'il allait faire
les arts qu'il allait faire sciences po
et il avait réussi tous les tests qu'est
ce qui vous a étonné
[Applaudissements]
on chiale balle il nous avait déçus tous
tout le monde était subjugué par la
débilité social à nos intelligences de
ce chien qui se lèchent et qui s'en fout
totalement de ce qu'on est en train de
faire une année d'humains vous cette
année est un chien si je me mets à
youtube une vidéo humaines de 10 minutes
en vaudra soit 110 mg le nombre de pubs
que je vais leur mettre sur on avait
ensuite fait la bouffe run pour tester
son agilité et on avait vu qu'il avait
un grand courage en fait l'intelligence
d'un chien c'est sa capacité à s'adapter
face à différentes situations et donc
j'ai checké pas mal de tests et de
petites épreuves qu'on peut faire à son
cher je les ai regroupés comme ça j'ai
créé mon propre test que vous allez
pouvoir faire à votre chien sauf la
seconde partie parce que ça avait de
l'agilité dons pour acheter des trucs à
décathlon on est un an après natsu a
maintenant un an et demi à l'époque il
avait 6 7 mois il était jeune il y avait
la foule il se laissait un peu trop vers
par ses émotions il était un peu
impulsif tout ça mais aujourd'hui je
m'en bats les couilles
mais aujourd'hui il a grandi et l'a mûri
il est plein de sagesse il aller coûte
il est attentif et vous allez voir qu'il
va passer ce test haut la main parce que
mon chien est intelligent par son team
et japonais sont principalement canin
est un vidéo de 10 minutes encore 70
c'est ce qu'ils font vraiment la
regarder juste au dessous mais qu'est ce
que la [ __ ] t'es mauvais bien ça
commence bien voilà comment je suis
censé faire mon business plan avec
l'octogénaire la dernière fois souvenez
vous je m'étais fait piéger j'avais pas
pris le dépliant 10 as et appétissante
que m'ont dit et du coup il s'en foutait
un peu de répondre aux ordres
aujourd'hui vous savez quoi ces sorties
du lot mon pote ça ou c'est un joueur
natsume chien ou un chat on attend à
l'hôpital celui-ci rêve à tous nous
épater il est très réactif ok dit que
jouer ils vont s'arranger
regardez bien des égards le bien des
aïeuls de la bouffe bon premier
l'épreuve pâtes ou ai-je bien c'est bien
mon chien ça c'est fait se boucher tient
certes aux premières épreuves envoie en
avant est ce que le chien va chercher ce
qu'on lui lance c'est un point s'il y
arrive c'est très simple regardez je
sors sont jouées 100% de chances de
réussite je ferme les yeux je sais qu'il
va y arriver ou home et ses angoisses à
regarder bien et c'est en quoi
c'est un point crois moi ça mais vous
lèche deuxième épreuve le rapport
d'objet c'est à dire le va chercher est
ce que le chien rapporte ce que son
maître vient de lui lancer écoutez moi
bien quand j'en vois un jouet il va
dessus quand j'en envoie un autre il va
chercher l'autre et il le met avec le
premier il fait un petit tas de jouets
mais un petit tas à une distance de
sécurité de moi même pour pas que je ne
puisse atteindre ce petit à la preuve
vas-y ramène ça n'a rien changé à ma
nuit ici provient revient première avec
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé mais
cette distance de sécurité non pas que
je ne puisse faire ça comme eto'o à la
prochaine fois que tu dors à la maison
protège bien tes couilles et [ __ ]
quand je préfère bâtisse va chercher à
manara ménard mais la balle est d'amener
dragonnades sous un poids plus c'est
bien pas de pot oui merci bien mais je
veux bien vous voyez qu'il a dit à temps
alors je suis donc à deux points sans
triche ça ça me fait très plaisir
ok on va tester l'immobilité le chien
doit rester immobile hors de la vue du
maître un point alors je vais juste le
prendre le jouer sinon c'est trop facile
voyez je suis sincère observa là dedans
pas bougé attends attends
enfin je vais retourner à mon business
plan
bon alors j'en étais lui a remis le
contenu pour ma chaise je pourrais
peut-être faire un tuto pour apprendre à
bien si la chesnaie la suite ça va se
passer sur la terrasse parce que j'ai
besoin de plus d'espacé
n'as tu viens voir ce que tu peux
expliquer à ces gens pourquoi tu est
inactif surtout qu'on installe toi qui
as plus de 600 mille fans natsume
question celle où un dealer mais c'est
toi le spip y échanger de gérer cela
j'ai vu comme une teigne ces femmes
il prend pas exemple sur moi c'est fou
mais c'est un beau gâchis n'en resta go
provoqué par pour écouter la raison
extrêmement simple j'ai perdu les
identifiants j'ai perdu les identifiants
d'un compte instagram qui a plus de 600
mille abonnés et ça fait des mois je
sais pas quoi faire bon mais côté
fabiola allait bien on sort aller
allons-y
c'est bon on va passer à la suite du
test il attend juste de sortir pour
sortir regardez bien maintenant sort
sont pas tant que tu m'as pas retrouvé
mes identifiants sort mais le parcours
comme ça lâche alemagne autour la suite
des épreuves messieurs dames le rappelle
on évalue la capacité du chien à
répondre à 100 m lorsqu'il l'appel alors
on va tester sa maintenance en
nourriture hockey l'animal est repéré il
se situe dans les fougères à l'autre
bout de la terrasse matsu c'est donc à
lui tout âge arrive bien dissimuler mon
grand étonnement piste il répondra plus
jamais à aucun ordre à partir de
maintenant berges du lez confondez m'ont
cassé les couilles dix stades de chiba
ils sont pas mal rancunier et regardez
bien il est ou pas il cherche yen à
trois bassins de vidéos frère vient
notes et ils étaient dans les poubelles
notre hopper [ __ ] ces gens qui sont
des gros porcs et qui met pas ça dans la
poubelle [ __ ] j'ai un chien de
gouttière bon c'est un sans faute pour
le moment on n'est plus d'accord avec ça
la suite aux pieds ici on va tester si
le chien suit son maître au pied sans
laisse aller c'est impossible
le tout je le rappelle c'est bien sûr de
le faire sans friandises parce que c'est
beaucoup trop facile nadia tu me suis
bien mais j'arrive mais reste loin des
stocks les six mois sur moi sur ma part
lundi à nice il n'hésite pas là tu mens
à dire tu me suis moi sûrement aller tu
le dis tout de suite je me suis impliqué
homme met donc les doigts
je travaille les jets seront à moins de
plus pour nice où il est maintenant
temps de passer à la dernière épreuve du
dressage une épreuve très classique qui
s'appelle le debout assis couché s'il
réussit les trois manches et un 10 sur
ok tous les rageux là on dit qu'il était
malade et 1 fois tous les rageux je vous
vois tu es prêt
platine debout mais oui je connais sa
sève des militants le conte à 6 ça c'est
bon on connaît aussi
ok coucher je viens à hawaï en perdons
pas regarde là au match aller les voir
qu'une ont bon allez pas il fait pitié
miss alalalala mais on montre au monde
de quoi nous sommes capables et stoxx
600 tu m'a saoulé il est toujours obligé
problèmes psychologiques
je le vis bien vous en faites vous 10
sur 10 pour tout ce qui est épreuve de
dressage il l'est il doit mener ce n'est
pas parce que j'ai donné des friandises
entreprises certainement pas on passe
donc maintenant aux épreuves d'agilité
je rigole déjà je sais qu'il ne va rien
respecté le but de cette activité de
réaliser un parcours avec des obstacles
sans réaliser de foot le plus proprement
possible en effectuant le meilleur temps
bien sûr sur le parcours le chien
contrôle à plusieurs obstacles début du
parcours lancé par l'arbitré au coup de
sifflet les et a sauté le chien doit
sauter par dessus des 3 points paraît
sauté du coup le maître n'a pas le droit
de sauter les avants a assez horrible on
fait des intrus dans l'éducation si ton
chien galère à faire une action il faut
que toi tu la face et en te voyant faire
il va comprendre et prendre confiance et
il va la faire aussi se trouve ainsi que
de la merde ensuite nous retrouvons
l'épreuve du slalom le chien doit
effectuer le parcours en slalom le
maître n'a pas le droit de montrer
l'exemple en effectuant le parcours avec
lui il y aura ensuite l'obstacle du tube
le chien doit passer dans le tube son
maître et or à l'arrivée c'est mort et
enfin on finira par le cerceau le chien
doit passer dans le cerceau en sautant
5.6 réussite [ __ ] ça paye bien ça il
faut qu'il y arrive bourses à des
problèmes est obligé de fonctionner la
récompense gustatives que je n'ai pas
utilisé jusqu'à présent à aucun moment
mais là je vais être obligé de le faire
parce que sinon il ne fera vraiment
jamais c'est sûr et certain
allez on y va ok maps tu as intérêt à me
faire honneur aux non stop les simples
au discours je te fait une promesse si
tu réussis mon fils en me faisant
honneur que tu passes chacun choisit
motifs toi tout seul tu m'appelles quand
tu as fini
c'est fou hier au décathlon et toi tu me
pète indices nous comme si c'étaient les
vidéos c'est fou et là mon fils
bon ok mais après je te plaît peu
importe quand tu mettras on s'en fiche
du temps après j'ai si tu prends ton
courage à deux mains et que tu réussi à
passer chaque obstacle je te promets de
retrouver tes identifie un style et tu
pourras faire tous les placements que tu
veux tu seras un chien roi est plus un
chien dégoût attentes a dit que j'étais
un chien de kuala
daisy aller qu'on en finisse contrôle et
de blu il va chercher ce qu'ils
voulaient ça commence si mark rutte un
récit on évite le bleu rouge sont sales
et on évite le peloton non non non tu
vas pas me faire ça saute la sorte mais
vous ferez bon ben ok non mais il se
fout de ma gueule en plus la job non la
cfl tour sa première moyens j'ai bon là
on passe à la pluie il croit bien faire
puisque n'arrivant qu'en j'ai eu des
sautes c'est pour qu'il saute sur le
canapé ou sur un truc en hauteur viens
ici car j'habite là je comprends plus
quoi saisissent hot shots
non
[Musique]
ça a payé l'impatience jack ya encore de
la boue à naujac
où ai-je dit ok on continue il a fait
vous allez vous vous allez devoir jeter
a sauté ok bien la valse à leur mire à
vialas tesco c'est divertissant pour les
gens sont là là là là c'est sûr tu peux
pas retourner au gaming vous faire ça
avec ma claque et carlito tiens si le
passé l'expression sur le visage d'un
père fier de son enfant à des 11-15 fils
très tôt à trop bien essayé mais y'a
bien son nom mais où là tu m'as compris
mais non j'ai pas compris ça je mettrai
une heure leur saute mais je lis pas
qu'un chien enfin si mais bon c'est
millions à l'honneur donc ne te laisse
pas bâtir et ancien nom n'est pas peur
n'aie pas peur c'est du plastique du
plastique ça pue la planète c'est une
saloperie n'ai pas peur il s'attendait
pas à ce que ça tombe du coup il fait
une fixette
il passera plus jamais cet obstacle
c'est terminé on passe au suivant passe
au tunnel janati regarde regarde up
tiens mais ici il va faire le tour la
bouffe rire passe dedans
allez y à 3 croquettes au mieux tu
préfère faire les poubelles que d'aller
prendre des friandises ici oui natsu je
vais tenter tous attendaient y avait pas
marché pour le tunnel bad run lui
montrer alors on s'y colle tout le monde
regarde mais il le fait mon corps ici
fin que je passe dans ce carton qu'il
fallait à l'argent de mon chien c'est
bon bon goût tu t'emballes et kouyias -
oui mais non là on a perdu et commencent
à regarder le soleil les oiseaux on a
complete and on regarde on aller pour
philips business plan
oui si je faisais une vidéo qui
s'appelait la face cachée de ce musée
les mots jeepers creepers aux noms mal
son salaire je sais il a soif sais pas
si c'est en train d'assister un très bon
moment entre un père et son fils
allez on y va aller bien rire bienvenus
rires bien dans le tunnel via l'arrière
bien regarde chez rona dessous bisous
mon chien ou [ __ ] mais ils y
retournent le conte hockey j'attends un
petit jeu mental et on tient là tu tiens
nat
bon on passe aux assauts mais qu'est ce
que c'est ça natsu c'est un beau ses
ressources
t'aurais pas envie de passer d'or à 3 ha
ok j'ai deux freins 10 à la viande
rien rien 26 et des nouvelles regardes
tu l'as centimes à nantes et appâter à
ayet 16 à 10 août via la soute
sans aucune aide bien mélanger la
colombie la course bien via la viola oui
oui on l'a fait tchèque silvio j'ai pas
des lâches et du tchèque
c'est bon allez va dormir maintenant tu
as bien travaillé mon chien tu veux
savoir ta note tu vas salle art and hot
il est temps de conclure ce merveilleux
slalom les et a sauté
natsu a sauté une et sur les deux qui
lui fait donc trois points les cerceaux
natsu est passé dans le cerceau cinq
points il est donc à huit le slalom
nacho effectué le slalom il est donc à
13 le tube natsu a échoué au tube on est
donc un trait sur 20 pour les preuve
d'agilité et un 10 sur 10 pour l'épreuve
de dressage ce qui nous fait une moyenne
de 17 sur 20 on a fait j'ai retrouvé ton
code instant là je vais retrouver ton
cousin star tu vas être le chiffre le
plus riche de la toile t'inquiète pas tu
auras des fontaines de croquer à tu fais
[Musique]
quoi cela il comprend ma joie il sait
pas pourquoi mais comprend que je suis
content allez bonne chance avec l'auteur
à [ __ ] lundi elle plus douce à des
glaces or les amis c'est la fin de cette
deuxième vidéo avec natsu et dernière
dorénavant vous appréciez son chien à sa
juste valeur en tant que chien supérieur
aux autres chiens
c'est sûr que je dis non sans déconner
c'est toujours très bien de faire votre
oeil son chien lui faire face
exo assigné coucher de la pâte et c'est
ça les stimule c'est très bien voilà
c'est la fin de cette vidéo avec cette
phrase finalement très pauvre dans ce
qu'elles transmettent les nuages passent
un bon moment avec mon chien et je suis
content de ça effectivement il n'est pas
très malin
effectivement il a des peurs et des
craintes et finalement n'est ce pas le
reflet de son maître ultimate sont
totalement il a donc les mêmes craintes
la même petite corpulence la même envie
taux se pentifie la même obstination f
il s'agit de mon chien savant des
communs avec la musique au montage
c'était pas mal je pense un bon je vous
dis à bientôt j'espère quand même ça
vous aura plu même si c'est un peu le
grand complexe et votre chien s'il a
regardé cette vidéo avec vous et aucune
honte ou quoi voilà ciao bon courage
avec vos chiens pas intelligent bisous
tout le monde à merci et au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est lourd